during doha's hot summers when
temperatures hit above 45 degrees
celsius most people tend to stay indoors
but staying cool here in a district of
the qatari capital known as mushrib is
much easier it's been designed as a
so-called smart city from the control
room for all the infrastructure that has
been built from the beginning of the
designing the project as well as was
built to be a smart city where it could
accommodate all the platforms for all
the future users that is going to be
within the city
sustainability experts gathering in doha
for this year's smart city expo sema
cherub is an example of how innovation
and new technologies can be used to cut
co2 emissions and tackle climate change
they say urbanization and population
growth mean more smart cities are needed
in the future
there are nearly 8 billion people in the
world and 55 of them live in cities but
the un says that number is expected to
rise to 68 by the year 2050 with close
to 90 percent of this increase happening
in asia and africa
we have a few challenges in today's
world like sustainability like
innovation
like
having a better integration of
everybody's better life in uh within a
city and
those challenges
you have smart cities and cities that
are not so smart and the world will be
thanking those who are bringing smart
solutions
scientists say new technologies in
cities will help bring down greenhouse
gas emissions
those attending this expo say they hope
it'll provide a road map on how to get
there victoria gatenbee al jazeera doha